you are saying
to the human race for the first time an
official
intelligence representative is saying
publicly
we are not alone we're definitely not
alone absolutely the data points
empirically that we're not alone yeah
this is uh this is one of the things
that the Sci-Fi writers and and
filmmakers of the past got wrong we got
a lot right but one thing they got wrong
is they always assumed that going
through all these different hypothetical
scenarios of when we make contact with
aliens or when aliens come to United
States they always assumed that
no matter what else happens it would be
a big deal to the people on earth like
it'd be the biggest deal of all
[Music]
and they got that wrong because uh a lot
of people don't care yeah the U.S
intelligence official that comes out on
the record and says yes we have these
vehicles we have them and everyone's
like oh no
who cares okay Bears I don't care I
don't care I want someone to explain to
me it doesn't mean that you yeah you can
always find a reason to doubt anyone
when they're when they're making a claim
of something you haven't seen for
yourself but when you're assessing the
veracity of someone's claim you look at
a couple of things you look at their
resume their you know their own
background you know to see if if what
they're if there's any reason they would
know this then this is not a
credentialism thing it just what I mean
is if someone's saying oh I have seen
top secret classified documents proving
this well now the credentials do matter
because I want to know are you the sort
of person who would even have access to
that and if you aren't then I'm not sure
that I probably won't believe you in
this case he is the kind of person would
have access to that information so you
want to look at that the other thing you
want to assess is what is in it for this
person if they're lying what could they
gain from lying but as we talk about
there are a lot there's a lot of other
evidence and uh McKenna has compiled
other UFOs citing videos uh and I don't
think I have any context on any of these
really so I don't know where any of this
happened do we know where any of this
happened there's just random Youtube
videos of UFOs now it is darkened
outside temperatures are sitting at 61
in Buffalo we have a Northerly wind at
seven good sleep and weather tonight
folks uh you what was that did anybody
see that thing go past did we just see a
shooting star
on Skywatch that was awesome did we see
it again I missed it in Buffalo we have
a Northerly wind at seven good sleep and
weather tonight folks uh you what was
that did anybody see that thing go past
did we just see a shooting star yeah
look at that I don't know about that one
I mean yeah it's probably aliens but
look they're not all gonna be winners
okay but many of these are very good
okay just go go to the next one
this is from 1994.
and this is in Norway
I mean
what else could that
blur on the screen be but aliens
I'm starting to destroy my own case here
look they're they're not not all these
sightings are created equal but also uh
another thing to keep in mind is that
because there's also a question people
asking about uh why why is it like we're
seeing more and more of these recently
and what's what's that all about is it
some sort of mass hysteria sort of thing
and I think that it's not it's just that
now we actually have the capability to
record this which could also explain
the other question is well if the
government was lying about this for
decades and now you've got some
government officials coming out and
saying yeah this might be real and
you've got even Congress doing hearings
and investigations and taking it
seriously well what explains that like
did they have a a come to Jesus moment
do they decide to start being honest I
think no I think instead first of all
you got a couple of a few whistleblowers
who are forcing their hand a little bit
and also because of modern technology
and the information age and video and
social media it they're not able to lie
about this stuff the way that they used
to it's almost like their hand their
hands are being forced because people
have cameras now on their phones and
they can capture these kinds of videos I
have over 200 000 pictures I got
pictures of this pop
s it's a very recent phenomenon where
everybody has a high-powered camera with
them all the time and so it makes sense
that now we're starting to see a lot
more of this
than we did before and I also think that
it might make sense that we're being
visited uh we're attracting more
interest from these uh entities hey UFO
has landed in America the only country
UFOs ever seem to land in because we
have so much technology as many of you
know I'm constantly traveling being on
the road as much as I am I don't sleep
very well at night I know it's uh
because the hotel sheets are not as
comfortable as my cozy Earth sheets
which I have at home I can't bring with
me when I go to hotels unfortunately
Cozier sheets are the softest most
luxurious sheets I've ever owned my wife
and I have their white bamboo sheets on
our bed these bamboo sheets are
temperature regulating they help us
sleep like a sweet babies even on hot
sticky nights cozy Earth offers an array
of sizes and colors to match your Unique
Style and preferences their sheets are
made to withstand the test of time my
cozy Earth sheets get softer and softer
with every single wash don't just take
my word for it they have over 5 000
happy customer reviews on their site
what are you waiting for cozy Earth
offers 100 night guarantee so there's no
harm in trying it invest today in a good
night's sleep right now you'll save 40
off your next purchase with promo code
Walsh at cozyearth.com that's promo code
Walsh cozyearth.com uh all right this
next one is just supposed to be in
California it doesn't look like
California let's say California has
changed quite a lot um okay let's watch
this
and now we're talking
that right there you see it turning
around
the turn is really significant because
that tells you it's not like some kind
of blimp or balloon
the other thing and it's also important
that in these sightings there's
similarities between them and uh
oftentimes it's not possible like how is
that even staying in the sky it doesn't
appear to be any uh propulsion mechanism
that we recognize a lot of times there
aren't any wings that we can see so it
defies our understanding of physics in
the first place we also have some of
these pentagons so these are some of the
footage that uh the Pentagon has
released let's go to clip 10.
oh my gosh
they're all going against the wind the
wind's 120 knots
this this one to me is probably the most
convincing of all the videos we've seen
it
is
rotated
yeah I mean these are these are these
are military Pilots
capture this stuff on radar
[Music]
okay
all right well what is that that's my
question you know what okay we can stop
um
if you don't want to entertain and I'm
not saying you have to
automatically believe that those are
aliens but if you don't want to even
entertain that possibility
then what are your competing theories
that's the other thing I haven't heard
very many compelling competing theories
and all the competing theories I hear
are to me are not persuasive especially
the theory that uh that this is
technology from some adversary that we
have so you're telling me that China or
some other uh it would have to I don't
know what other country would even
potentially be the Russians the Chinese
martians Canadians I don't care so China
has technology
that is so far Advanced of us that it
looks impossible again so far Advanced
that our own military pilots who do this
for a living okay they're in the skies
they're looking at anomalous craft and
they're looking at enemy and and it's so
Advanced that our own Pilots don't even
know what it is so Advanced that our own
Pilots have to consider that it might be
aliens and our adversaries have that and
they haven't at this point just taken
over the world completely if they have
technology that appears to be
otherworldly in origin because it's so
Advanced then you would think they could
just take over the world and why would I
mean why would another Earthly entity
another Earthly government have
technology that that is that far ahead
that it would seem impossible that
doesn't make sense
and it makes even less sense that it's
our technology and we're trying to fool
our enemies by saying it's not ours it's
aliens if there's never been anything
visiting Earth that even could
potentially be otherworldly in origin
China would know that
and so they're not going to be fooled
uh anyway all right
talk tomorrow
[Music]